cancel these nuts yeah yeah it's here y
got the hard copies old schol yo I
haven't seen a real like dope CD in a
while it's really dope too I like man we
did a team we really put that together
and it's nice came out so
nice oh yeah it's really nice this is a
real CD yeah yeah replicate it people
can go online and get the autograph
version the [__]
store.com I like that now let me ask you
something when you do something called
the [__] store.com are there other Crips
that feel some type of way that they're
cuz you know there's there's um so many
Crips there's [__] Cola sure there was
the shout out to Mike there was the
Crips that claimed like [__] LLC that
tried to sue nipc yeah that was fun um
so you have the Crips store does anyone
own the Crips uh I don't know on the
business side I don't know I wouldn't
even really worry about it I wouldn't
even think twice about it it seems like
a non-p thing to do the [__] store no no
no I'm saying like a non-p thing to do
to be like I trademarked that it's
definitely a non-p thing to do I don't
know any Crips actively looking
to copyright that term to Crips I just
would say it's just a bit broad you know
I I think most cribs look at it like
it's just a broad concept we all being
right in the eye of the stor
isers and everybody their own claim to
it as far as Angeles goes and now across
the world um I listen to the album my
favorite is the uh 21 stemi flow that's
tight I liked uh us with d smoke that
was dope one of the guy La Giants had a
uh La Giants are on that record right y
yeah it was both of them Joe and the
first verse that they did was super dope
when they were like Kendall Jenner
wouldn't have her lips oh yeah yeah
that's Joey Joey West he killed that
[__] yeah yeah you're right yeah and he
went right before Cam and you know
that's Cam's that's right within uh West
Coast Cam's wheelhouse my OG West CO bro
yeah that's his wheelhouse so for Joey
to go he he got off yeah no he did his
thing man album is dope um it's kind of
like a it feels like a little like
obviously it's your album but you you
obviously have the uh La Giants heavily
intertwined throughout the project yeah
they just fit what was going on at the
time are they like blue division
no no they got they got their own label
giant life okay I just Market their
stuff okay so I mean I guess they are
blue division to some degree but really
it was about helping them build their
own thing yeah you take a liking to them
and wanted to
help um I I've been knowing them
probably 20 years you know what I mean
I've always liked them but I just think
uh God created a space I forgive me for
getting all extra spiritual but he
created a space and I realized we had so
many things in common this late in our
life
and so [__] we just start working and
they was talking about jumping on
records and I just long as they had fun
and they end up being like way better
you know what I mean than I ever could
have thought like I would have never
thought walking into it we was going to
be making this many records we talking
my cut cord cord cut out we're talking
about the LA Giants obviously they're
all over the project yeah um they just
fit they just fit we the same type of
it's crazy is because all of these
artists I've worked with um I can't say
everybody had as much of La experiences
I have right everybody hasn't been a
gang banger if they have they haven't
low they haven't had a low rider been on
CR YW um if they have you know maybe
they never sold dop or if they have
maybe they never Street raced you maybe
they never functioned the LA Johns was
like the first acts that I worked with
to me that did all of the same La things
that I
did including risk your life for some
good chicken yes yeah yeah it's [__]
true which is a which is song number
seven yeah Jim Dandy but it's like that
in so many different places it's funny
because that's like a TV show I'm
finishing up I rode and I'm F to shoot
uh van Le a couple homies helping me to
produce it but um dying at your own risk
that's the experience in La yeah there
are always people who are like yo man
there's some great cuz what's the the OG
Louisiana chicken is where an a tray and
it's like if if you're over there danger
it's dangerous but that's how it is uh
so Jim dandies and Denver Lang Bloods
right then you have Hawkins Andross
street from the Nickerson Gardens the
Bon um Lou the best chili cheese fries
in Compton is right in the mob Hood you
just kind of got to figure out how to
get to all of these places and get away
with it and when you go you got to like
really just not have on your your stuff
right like you would I'm I'm past that
people knew who I I mean people know who
you are yeah but I'm saying it's been a
long time they could smell a [__] like
people could smell gang banging other
gang bangers can smell other gang
bangers that's why if they like hit you
up like oh where you from like oh man uh
where you who's your mama where you live
where you grew up at like you know
they'll smell out they could tell yeah I
mean I've always uh head always tells me
and I don't know if this is good advice
or bad advice but he said if I ever end
up somewhere and I have a couple of
times where I was getting gas somewhere
and I called Head this happened like he
posted it on Instagram cuz I hit him and
I was like yo I'm right here am I good
to get something to eat I'm getting gas
and he's like what the [__] [__] are you
doing there yeah but he head would
always say he's like yo if you end up
somewhere and you get banged on just
start acting like real frantic like
you're in the middle of a crazy fight
with your girl and you got lost like man
my bad bro sorry man [__] fighting
with my [__] bro I don't know where
[__] cuz that's a universal masculine
thing we all be like oh man man I just
got caught cheating thisit tripping bro
he like man she [__] had me get out
the car my bad bro do your thing yeah
yeah man my bad you know that's what
head said it's true it works it works he
like just just act like you're in the
middle of a crazy fight with your girl
you don't know where you're at and you
know get on your phone and like it
should be all right yeah yeah yeah now
for the most part it's okay I mean gang
bangers the most underrated part about
gang banging is they're pretty
understanding yeah if they sober if
they're
sober like most humans that's like hey I
about to say that's a pretty general
statement for the world but gang banging
it get worse when you know you drunk
because you get superpowered and people
be charged up yeah like my wife when she
gets mad if she's drunk and mad it's
over it's over Latina oh yeah that's
Spanish cuss words Spanish cuss words
yeah there's a lot of Spanish cuss
wordss I've been called um okay so if
someone gets your CD physically and they
look at the back you have obviously you
got West Coast cam you got sugarfree
shout out to sugar free the legend I
need you to help me get connected with
him sure I got you I got you um but then
you also have Samuel Jackson and the
notorious b listed as features yeah yeah
yeah um explain both I just feel like
it's always weird when you looking at a
track list and somebody voice pop up who
the [__] is that and I just put that
there like um obviously on Spotify I
didn't try to infringe on their
audiences but I wanted people to know
that that voice you hear is going to be
Biggie or this voice is going to be
Marther King or Samuel Jackson or that's
fair Cedric the Entertainer you also
have um the guy who plays Jesus um in
the music video for slink slink Johnson
yeah shout out to slink Johnson he did a
really good job on uh Freddy Gibbs album
too he kind of was like a
he did one of the skits on his album uh
and he did great on your music video
yeah yeah uh what's it save something
for the [__] for [__] some for the
[__] for [__] which is um an Ode
to uh it's weird because right there's a
men with bedazzled anklets that and just
just stray men impeding on women's
beauty standards in the first place
completely top to bottom I tell them all
the time straight man Cyrus my shooter
over there got two earrings in that you
know what's funny that 30 40 years ago
that would have been lit FR at 20 years
ago that's normal mhm when I was growing
up my dad used to always tell me if you
have an earring on a certain side it
meant that you were gay yeah oh yeah
like the right side right and if you
have both it's like what girls do yeah
that's true and that that used to be
that way that used to be that way then R
Kelly kicked that down cuz he had them
things him and AI you know what I'm
saying